[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
Willian yes Dom we are here in the
Friendship onion Studios hey not only
are we in the French bunny Studio but
today we have a guest
um
and we don't have a huge amount of time
so we should we can't be messing around
himself well something fell on the Shelf
careful
peeling The Onion
we should really just fire that in but
yeah should we do one miniature piece of
housekeeping before we go ahead
hey we've got a ton of questions and
keep them coming in because we will get
to your questions eventually we'll do an
episode that's all about questions at
some point but we're just gonna uh
answer one this is from Vic in Austria
hello Vic hello Vic who said what do you
think of the meme below and does Samwise
gamji have a point or not now hopefully
at this point we're putting the meme up
on the screen via the gift of Technology
but not on the podcast
the the meme I'll explain it it is that
the end of The Return of the King where
Frodo has unfortunately passed out and
lost control of his limbs oh yeah
remember Sam says I can't carry the ring
Mr Frodo but I can carry you up you get
any and he carries him up the hill right
and Andrew Nadal at the Andrew Nadal on
Twitter yeah above the photo and said
Sam being able to carry Frodo and not be
affected by the ring means the ring
doesn't understand
transist transitive yeah transitive
properties so they could have just taped
the ring to a mouse and then carried the
mouse with no ill effect the whole
journey would have taken 20 minutes now
it's a good point but I would think
probably a less Dynamic movie trilogy
and if actually you made it three or
four things way like if you had stapled
it onto a tarantula
poor tarantula then tied the tarantula's
legs around the mouse poor tarantula
that hurt the mouse into the
forward-facing pocket of a kangaroo yeah
put the kangaroo into uh one of those uh
like a little trolley
and then push the the uh and then just
go through all pulled there up up the
hill that would seem almost as hard as
carrying Elijah Wood up a hill I would
argue whereas popping a mouse in your
pocket and going for a stroll seems to
be less
I'm just trying to get it I'm trying to
get it further away I understand
hey William what
should we bring in our guest come on
it's a fantastic guess why don't you
read a little blurb for us dumb before
we get started I'll read a little blurb
about our guests Brent
Pella
is a stand-up comedian in digital
content creator and cast on VH1's wild
and out
Brent's comedy videos have gained more
than 100 million views combined to an
audience of over 400 000. it's a lot of
people across social media Brent
graduated through both the Groundlings
and UCB Upright Citizens Brigade improv
sketch come uh uh programs in LA and is
best known for his viral impressions of
Eminem
Joe Rogan and California governor Gavin
Newsom amongst others as well as
uniquely handcrafted video comedies or
comedy videos that tackle everything
from politics to spirituality cultural
Trends and more William
let's welcome on to the Friendship onion
Brent what a welcome
Tom here we have our beautiful guest for
this week hello brother what's going on
how's it going Brenton only a beautiful
guest but Brent Eve my God you stop
moving around everything's touching
everything you're causing the
earthquakes now I'm sorry you've brought
us gifts let's talk about it bearing
gifts thank you yes bro uh you know this
is the Friendship onion so I figured the
first layer
could be made with a gift what a lovely
you know and if it's the gift of booze
then it's even better Prince Tis the
gift of booze this is uh rose wine brand
that I've been working on for the past
couple of years it's called Vibe Rose
super Stokes excited that it's finally
out I brought you each a bottle so sweet
yeah man now as someone who obviously is
behind is chilled as well someone who's
behind this company tell us what defines
this above all the other roses out there
there are many roses out there uh rose
by any other name would smell as sweet I
don't think that's what this is that's
close yeah uh you know a lot of roses I
grew up with rose not grew up because
you're not supposed to drink under 21.
uh my whole family is Italian so they
kind of introduced me to Rose
um early on and then I just kept coming
back to it I'm a wannabe wine nerd and
coming out of 2020 I wanted to do
something else to help people stop
yelling at each other on Twitter right
just kind of just kind of connect in
real life and look each other in the
eyes again you know and uh and so I take
a lot of what I do in like the comedy
space and the live event space and I
wanted to put it into this brand and
this product what the mission of
creating something that's a little more
high energy because a lot of roses
they're a little bit standoffish a
little bit fancy a little bit high brow
I wanted this to be a little more
approachable relatable and kind of
synonymous with live event culture and
people going out and having an
accessible
where do you get it how can people get
it yeah it's at viberbrose.com vyb
rosc.com uh promo code is vibrate with a
white lovely but uh yeah the juice comes
from Napa it's it was a crazy process to
get going and you know it was my first
sense of that part of the world but do
you mind if I cracked main open and had
a little drink I really would be
offended if you didn't see you won your
offender guess no no I don't want to
offend anyone Johnny is there any
glasses for instance that would be
absolutely dead again for the rosie well
Brenda I've known family for 20 years
now and one of the real kind of epochs
in Billy's life is to run correct me if
I'm wrong to run a roasting hot bath
like almost as hot as like molten lava
and to dip himself into that thanks
Johnny Clues to dip himself into that
bath over the course of about 25 minutes
because it's so hot he almost scold him
really hard
on his on his bum and his genitalia
especially good then he puts on either
the Divine Comedy lovely possibly an old
LP from Annie DeFranco light some
candles
with her guest here yes Dean Martin oh
lovely Dean Martin yeah when the moon
hits your eye like a big
he likes a few candles one of those
candles is an Angelic
um version of Sean Aston looking
directly deeply into his eyes and then
if you don't mind me saying Billy thank
you that's fine
Billy likes to get absolutely rat ass
drunk and his favorite way of getting
drunk is on a rose so that when he
stands up out of his roasting hot bath
he almost passes out yeah and his wife
has to pick him up like like Sam picked
up Frodo and Lord of the Rings let's
carry him to the bedroom you love that
like I think like well she Whispers my
precious my precious like a bag of
washing you know when you've just gone
yeah I'll tell you what I can't wait
let's have a go at this come on yeah
cheers bro now Cheers Cheers Cheers over
there guys I can't quite reach it I'm
good oh what a lovely Bookie I'm getting
um tones of
well hmm Rose one that's actually really
smart are you trained I I do have a very
uh redefined nose because of all the
surgery William what are you getting
from that well a plastic cup yep yep
that was actually one of our ingredients
too and is this you're saying is this a
Californian yeah California Rose well
I'll tell you what that is absolutely
lovely it's lovely right thank you so
much this actually tastes to me
just have a little something if I were
to describe this Rosie I would say this
tastes like a kind of
accessible Rose like a rose that you've
already known yes you've known forever
that you parted with once and some crazy
stuff happened and you woke up and you
forgot about all this stuff but every
time you see the rose you feel this
connection exactly you had a great night
and then you found out that she texted
your friend and it got a bit weird a
couple years later she was like I only
texted him to ask about you and you're
like oh it's a misunderstanding
misunderstanding go out for ramen and
you accidentally get a little fragment
on it on your face but she doesn't tell
you and then you go home and you see and
you think how long has that been right
and that causes a fight between you
right but then you get married and have
four kids it's that type of dream that's
the exact way my parents met it's so
incredible here there was a little piece
of almost done egg yolk on the chin from
the ramen yeah it's a classic Love Story
what made you think about making a wine
what was that uh you know it was really
just I felt like creatively coming out
of covid in in 2020. yeah yeah I just I
felt like I wanted to do more I wanted
to give people another reason to smile
and laugh same way I do with comedy but
I figured Rose has such a great
Crossover with the live entertainment
space lovely just want to bring some
more joy you know who and like I think
of it as a sort of European a French
drink who drinks It in America Rosie
ladies
yeah yeah yeah summer and fall girls who
maybe they'll take like a a girls trip
together to like Salem and pretend to be
witches too right right the lowly
electrical toffee and and make really
safe bonfires yeah no light candles in
the shape of a pentagram and talk about
each other's times of birth and they'll
drink Rose at the same time wear cowboy
boots yeah
let's get let's get like Butch guys
drinking it then oh my God this is
fantastic
dudes can like roses
there's no rules
um well brenta what we really enjoy
doing on this show is not only having
people as yourself on the show who have
clearly followed their passion and
become successful but we like to hear
how that happened so that if there was
someone at home
who's possibly thinking about doing
something that you do you could provide
like a little bit of a road map for them
so could you could you give us like a
little kind of introduction as to how
you got going in the business absolutely
yeah yeah so I uh I went to school up in
Santa Barbara
um and in college I was doing a lot of
like silly videos comedy videos this was
around the time the uh The Lonely Island
guys were really big Andy Samberg and
the Saturday Night Live guys yeah so
they were a huge inspiration so I was
doing comedy music videos in college and
it was getting really popular around
campus and then I moved to LA and I
wanted to get into comedy but I didn't
know like what you're supposed to do to
get into comedy I was lost I didn't know
that stand-up was like a thing people
did for a career I thought it was like a
side thing that actors did sometimes
right and to interject were you were you
the funny kid at school were you the
class clown I was never even the
funniest of my friend group I still
don't think I am because it's like you
know how when you're around your friends
there's that one guy that's just always
hilarious yeah like you have that guy
yeah but he might not end up being the
funniest guy on stage or in a different
environment so there's still guys I
laugh harder at than anybody laughs at
me I'm in the Jerry Seinfeld saying
someone was interviewing him I can't
remember and they said were you the
funny kid in your social group and he
said no he said when you're a kid
everyone's funny everyone because
everyone's just trying to crack everyone
else up but you're all just like kind of
being a little bit light-hearted so he
said my entire social group was just
full of Goofs and comedians yeah which I
think is probably true when you look
back at it everyone's trying to make
other people yeah we're all trying to
bust each other down in junior high in
high school and
um so I moved down to La I started doing
open mics I was awful just absolutely
terrible but I played Sports my whole
life so I always had this very strong
like Competitive Edge too and so being
bad at something was like kind of
exciting for me so I I completely dove
in uh my first job when I moved out here
was at the Cheesecake Factory all right
well uh Glendale uh it was uh the
Beverly Hills Mo the mall what's that
big mall called no no
there's a Cheesecake Factory in there it
used to be a um the Grand Lux Cafe right
and then they closed down moved me out
to Marina del Rey to The Cheesecake
Factory uh you know how other countries
make you serve in the Army for two years
yeah I feel like in America we need to
make people work at a restaurant for two
years yeah yeah because you really learn
a lot about life
yeah so when you were doing open mics
yeah who who were the very successful
comedians that would come in and steal
an hour from everyone yeah who was who
was popping off um Brent Morin is super
funny Chris D'Elia was uh at kind of the
peak of his stuff
um Beth Stelling was around uh
people like Whitney Cummings were
starting to really pop off like that
um so I would see them sometimes at like
some of the bigger open mics and they
would come in and drop us out and would
these people be kind of gracious enough
to kind of say hey this is what I would
do I do it like this this uh began if
you asked yeah yeah it's uh Folks at
higher levels are like moving so quick
that they might have just popped in to
do their set and then dipped out sure
not for any mean reason because they got
busy stuff to do right so I was doing uh
a lot of open mics I started at
Groundlings and UCB the sketch programs
and I was also doing a lot of PA stuff
on the side uh as kind of a day job in
addition to the restaurant work and just
kept making videos and kept trying weird
stuff and kept like getting outside of
my comfort zone doing like celebrity
Impressions topical sketches things like
that and it all just kept growing and
building together
um and I'd say there were two real like
moments that I saw good things happen
one was coming into 2020 I started doing
a lot of like topical parodies making
fun of all the craziness that was going
on and then that caught the eye of Nick
Cannon who actually dm'd me on Instagram
to invite me to join the cast of Wild
and out very cool so yeah the all the
video stuff that I just kept pumping out
like spending my last tip dollars from
the Cheesecake Factory to make sure I
could get this prop for a video and then
be broke again and just kept going it
finally ended with you know getting a
gig on my own so I was going to back out
a lot of your videos and they're really
great thank you so much and really
topical and you know really really
interesting and kind of um smart stuff
but did you who was making the videos
did you have a little group of people or
were you totally there yourself telling
someone what to do like yeah did that
build up yeah it definitely built over
time you know because I was a PA for so
many years I had like a first-hand look
to proper Union gigs so I could see the
hierarchy of the crew and I got to like
look over the director shoulder at his
storyboard and everything and I took a
lot of those lessons and I started
putting them into the comedy videos so
even if it was like a two or three
minute comedy video I'd have a shot list
a storyboard I I write all of it myself
and up until about six months ago I was
editing everything myself too but now I
have a DP partner of mine who who kind
of co-edits things with me
um and then maybe two or three people
that I write with a lot so we have a
little unit out here you know you always
had a little you had an ability to do
Impressions yeah yeah so that comes from
first well the first impression I ever
did was Eminem and singing or talking
rapping really angry because you know
he's always angry he is he's very He's
very mad like even if you gave him a
glass of Rose he'd be like you know
thank you and you'd be like I'm sorry
did I hurt you uh so I started doing the
Eminem Impressions and once that got
picked up and and really popular online
something switched to my head and I was
like wow I was always scared of doing
impressions because it's so outside of
my comfort zone but I saw some success
so I just started following that and
testing different celebrities different
Impressions I'm not the best voice guy
but it was cool to kind of get out of my
comfort zone and try something new yeah
it's weird right with Impressions but
then I've talked about it before there's
a weird Alchemy with Impressions where
sometimes
the people that get the impression
absolutely bang on perfect isn't really
what the audience are looking for the
audience yeah are very often looking for
you to make what defines them completely
extreme and ridiculous so if you're bang
on people like well I could just go to
the actual Source I could just watch the
guy what I'm looking for is something
ludicrous and ridiculous you know yeah
you have to kind of push it a little bit
and you do Rogan as well yeah what was
the thing that what was the tag with
Rogan like what's Rogan's thing Eminem
for sure and he's always just he's
always so curious about like anything
like you could tell him you could
describe how you're drinking a glass of
water and he'd be like whoa yeah so the
water
just kind of goes through your face hole
and he'd like break it down so
specifically
um but I mean you know he's the dad for
people who don't have dads you know for
guys in their 20s and 30s that don't
have dads and uh I I think he's great
yeah I think he's fantastic and yeah
favorite things about Roe uh Joe Ro is
um Joe Ro that's what I think is um he
just kind of lets it all hang out yeah
look I hunt of course you have strong
feelings about hunting I eat meat you
might have strong feelings about uh meat
as well but every so often I'm gonna
have like a cutting board with really
bloody elk on it and a bunch of yeah and
a bunch of like chili peppers and I'm
like a man and for breakfast I'm going
to eat hunks of Flesh and hot chilies
yeah and then jump into a sauna for
three hours at like 250 degrees it's
bananas those photos of him wait he
comes out of the sword and he's like he
looks like a melting Bean dude it's wild
I love it yeah it's so funny but he's
you know he's caught fire because I
think of that authenticity at no point
as he said I'm going to trim off the
edges you know and also
is obviously a huge fan of MMA and
obviously Quite A Gifted kickboxer back
in the day I listened to some of those
pods but my favorite uh pods that Joe
does are these people working in the
kind of almost experimental elements of
of medicine so people who are really
trying to work with different modalities
that at this point are still a little
out there yep and they're you know
they're taking big risks big big leaks
themselves personally uh like Paul
stamets is Amazing Horse damage is
incredible Zach Bush yeah so Zach Bush
changed my whole perception toward water
yeah yeah so now I try to only drink
like fancy Waters now yeah but it's
great what's he saying about what he
says uh he had a podcast with Aubry
Marcus do you know who Aubry yeah yes
the arnica
um and they dove into a conversation
about the
structure of water as it pertains to how
we consume water in this country and how
we've set up our water systems to
basically Force water through these
unnatural movements through these
unnatural processes of going through
pipes 90 degree angles forcing water
through small holes
and it it I'm I'm not the scientist so
everybody should definitely go listen to
somebody else but the recap was like
when you do that to water it reforms the
molecular structure of water and it
takes away any natural nutrients or
electrolytes that could be in there
magnesium potassium sodium which water
naturally picks up when it's going down
millions of Springs or whatever and
that's why spring water is supposed
supposedly better than purified or tap
so that is so Spring Water Wolf they
have is it that's the yeah yeah so he
was parking on Spring Water a lot but I
mean what are we seven more than 70
water 76 well is that from that body
book it could be nice really been
reading the same books it's actually
sexy from an Amy Man song oh is that
right 76 76. maybe yeah it could be
either one of those too so if we uh if
we are a massive percentage of us is
water and we're introducing that into
our body it should be the best version
that more than 50 of you isn't actually
you it's water no it's other things or
elk no it's other animals little tiny
things living on your bacteria and stuff
oh yeah like microscopic yeah organisms
so if 76 percent of use water and over
50 of you is organisms you basically
don't exist yeah whoa Billy you just got
really into that's a trap you got very
Joe Rogan there Billy yeah get me some
milk that's the fibros they've flown
through your veins is that made with
spring water I hope uh spring water and
a head of LSD oh lovely that's why Billy
went [ __ ] there I have people you know
taught my ear off quite a lot about
animals like you know I'm obsessed with
animals and um had a nature show for a
few years and people come over and say
you know the usual stuff I'm scared of
snakes I'm scared of spiders I'm scared
of bees I'm scared of wasps and bats and
stuff and I say you know keep in mind
that the vast majority of those animals
even if you're in the same room as them
have no idea that you exist but similar
to what you said bills I was like we
have animals that live on our face yeah
all the time when you wash your face
they don't come off they live in our
eyebrows they live in our eyelashes they
keep our eyelashes and eyebrows clean
and if they weren't there you'd have
problems with that part of your body
yeah and they like freak out and I said
you're only freaking out because you
know that like yeah if you've not known
that for 25 years you know so connect to
the idea that the natural world is a
huge part of us we are part of the
natural world as well and just relax
into it yes the problem comes up when
people are tense about it you know I'm
really scared about spiders and you're
like well there's not a spider now and I
understand if there was like if I was
holding onto a transition you might have
a reaction but they're even just talking
about it makes them feel tense so you're
creating these Pathways in your brain of
every time I mention the word spider I
feel tense and they say how do I fix
that and I say you should go research
great things about spiders research what
they do for our planet research positive
things and retrain those Pathways in our
brain and then you'll feel a little bit
more empowered you don't have to keep a
spider but you should definitely not be
absolutely losing your marbles when you
see one in your bathroom right because
it's not there to consciously harm you
it's just a part of the world right
right it's a part of the natural flow of
things right so yeah retraining your
pathway to overcome fears like that it
only opens you up to more opportunities
to shine absolutely so Brent so you
started doing these these videos that
started to kind of become popular and
gain some traction from that point when
you started to gain a strong strong
online following did it change your
stand-up comedy audience and routine
yeah yeah it did which was really funny
because it was mostly during 2020 I had
never done political comedy prior to
2020 and then covet hit and I wasn't the
biggest fan of the mandates you know and
I saw some other things like uh that our
beloved Governor Gavin Newsom was doing
um like the curfew type stuff and and
just his kind of hypocrisy a little bit
so I want to poke fun at that because I
didn't see very many other people poking
fun at that I saw a lot of folks you
know especially in mainstream comedy are
making fun of Donald Trump for being
loud and orange and I guess great we
should make fun of trump but we should
make fun of everybody and everybody
deserves to have a Target if they're
doing something silly yeah and so I
started kind of Dipping into that and
it's the same fear thing I was nervous
about doing it but the more I did it the
more comfortable I felt because I felt
like I was being more authentic to my
sensibilities when it comes to Comedy
and in doing so my audience changed and
only got stronger and I started like
attracting people to my live shows who
would come up to me after and start
talking about hey dude I saw that video
that's so funny like you're the only
person who has a perspective that is
similar to mine or like I love how you
play both sides and it was never I never
did it for the purpose of growing my
audience I did it because it felt most
authentic and the audience just started
to grow naturally so I was pretty stoked
on natural growth there's a few though
you know when a sort of Internet YouTube
sort of thing once you do get some
traction and people are like oh God I
see how many views I'm getting then do
you feel pressurized I need to get
another video out now and because I I
know I've seen a lot of people talk
about this and they feel like oh it's
just like this never-ending yeah people
won't entertained all the time now where
it used to be you would you know if you
had a good stand-up show I could do you
for two years you know you you maybe
think of another joke occasionally but
you have to invent a whole little movie
is crazy because the amount of content
that comes out you know there's what
like 100 million new videos per month
uploaded to YouTube something crazy like
that like there's Millions per day yeah
and the pressure is something I've
actively tried to not allow to you know
dictate my life or how I operate in the
comedy space
um and it's tough because it's a it's a
it's a it's a tricky balance I want to
be putting out yeah content constantly
for people but I also want to put stuff
out that speaks to what I truly enjoy or
what I truly believe and
um it's also tough because the big thing
in today's content landscape is trying
to stick to a niche you know everybody's
got their own Niche like this guy only
does this is what has this type of this
guy only does like you know straight to
camera making fun of whatever this guy
only does like right wing or left wing
or whatever it is and I'm kind of all
over the map I got like a JK Paul
impression followed by a video about
some Bros that I grew up with followed
by a Joe Rogan impression and it's just
all over but uh for me it's I try to not
pay attention to the pressure because it
would start to make fuzzy the better it
does the creative that I want to put out
yeah and then on a kind of day-to-day
basis you know because obviously it's a
job that you do do you have a kind of
set format of like I'm gonna tend to get
into my material just after breakfast or
does it come to you when it comes to you
or like how do you make sense yeah when
to do it uh a little of both uh I
definitely try to sit and write for at
least an hour every day even if it's
just free writing journaling whatever it
is but I take a lot of notes in my phone
especially traveling if I see something
silly I'll write down a note and then
when I get to my computer later I'll try
to flesh it out
um and it's also different for stand up
versus video stuff there's a lot of
intersection I'll take a lot of
characters from my videos and and
integrate them into the live stand-up
show
but I do a majority of my writing for
stand up just live and in the moment
kind of improvising yeah so the rest of
the writing is at the computer yeah nice
and who would be on your
Mount Rushmore of stand-up comedians oh
yeah that's how you guys all sit around
and yeah are you guys comedy fans too
yeah yeah now how many people are on
Mount Rushmore is it four I think it's
four all right I think it's four I can
do that yeah
oh man I'd say uh
got three now have you well I got four
all right okay do you want to go first
I'll go first okay so we don't throw you
off yeah Bill Hicks right nice
Jerry Seinfeld okay
George Carlin mm-hmm
Richard Bryan very good nice those are
American
well not included the Brits well well
it's American structure yeah
do you have a four really four American
four Americans I'm I'm opening it up are
you doing worldwide yeah okay
controversy yeah in the United States
they would put anyone that isn't
American on Mount Rushmore but you do
your thing William
we'll build a new Mountain yeah in
international waters yeah Billy Conley
lovely
Bill Hicks
Harry Hill oh you lost your mind
watching Harry Hill one time yeah it was
a stand-up in Britain oh yeah and I had
to leave I thought it was I thought I
was going to pee myself I was laughing
so hard so he gets up there for that
night yeah just for that one night yeah
Eddie Murphy
oh that's good yeah yeah uh I'm gonna go
um George Carlin oh yeah uh Eddie Murphy
even though he hasn't done stand up in a
very long rumors that he is going to
right yeah there's been around for a
while a couple rumors over the past few
years yeah
um so Carlin Eddie Murphy Bill Burr oh
nice up there for me for sure
I I love Richard Pryor but I haven't
watched enough of him I think if I said
Richard Pryor I don't think I'd be being
completely honest I like that you're
always trying to be honest with yourself
yeah I like I try I think it's good yeah
um
over there
yeah the fourth if we're talking about
greats
I guess Seinfeld man just because of the
way he changed he changed stand up you
know special he really did something new
and I like I was watching some of your
stand up as well oh yeah very funny
thanks man and and fast and energy it
was really good and honest as you're
saying yeah you did a very funny bit
about uh
people showing each other but then it
became making love oh was that nervous
yeah that was very funny thank you dude
you'd like it I'll watch it yeah I'll
send you we've been lucky enough to have
a few stand-up comedians on the show and
I always like to ask him how did they
deal with the Heckler because everyone's
dead oh dude uh
I I so yeah I have a couple of friends
that get like really mad and angry and
they'll like put a Heckler in their
place and I try not to do that because
it causes this like weird tension you
know what I mean like I don't want to
tell somebody to shut the can I curse
here no I don't want to tell somebody
shut up you know yeah I don't want to
like be mean to them right away but also
you kind of gotta shut the [ __ ] up right
so
um I try to I try to get through it by
actually like telling them straight up
as if we're talking one-on-one if they
keep shouting out it'll be like hey man
you seem like a great dude I would love
to have a conversation with you later I
might even invite you on my podcast but
what you have to do right now is not
make another sound for the next 37
minutes right you know what I mean and
then everybody will kind of laugh a
little bit right and hopefully that's
enough
um but it's definitely gotten to the
point before where I've had to kind of
lay the hammer down and say something to
poke fun at them or roast them in a way
to a lot of times It's associated with
someone maybe being a little drunk
always 100 of the time yeah with a bunch
of friends and they try to be brave and
then very often I've seen when I've been
at live comedy shows or if you've seen
anything online as soon as as the
spotlight goes on that person they then
get a little bit sheepish yeah like I
didn't mean that the show to all be
about me and you're like well that's
what's happening that's what's happening
you you you you did mean that right
because that's what you did I had a
Heckler a couple of weeks ago at a show
I did I did this joke about Trump and
Biden and I said something like you know
it was like uh America is changing
presidents from an old white guy to an
older whiter guy and I did a couple
other things like that and everybody was
laughing except this one woman in the
front who was just looking at me with
dead eyes
and I kept going with the bit and she
starts talking she starts saying like
you shouldn't be talking like that he
should why are you comparing them like
that that's so dumb and she kept saying
that so I eventually said ma'am you can
watch this hey everybody if you think
this is funny Make some noise of course
everybody applauds immediately and she's
the only one that's silent right and she
got up and walked out of the room and I
could not have been more happy that she
had left right you know what I mean yeah
because it's just like oh but she was a
[ __ ] for the wrong reason yeah it's
weird that isn't it that what I mean
that's the Karen thing isn't it crazy
that they
bring all of their thoughts and what
they think should be life to every
social occasion it's so weird to walk in
a comedy
yeah I mean fair if you wake up and walk
out fair enough yeah but why would
anyone feel that this is okay for me to
come in here yeah yeah this is crazy
yeah the entitlement is crazy yeah and
it's getting worse and worse obviously
everyone everyone feels like they have
an opinion and that it's relevant like
obviously everyone has an opinion but
social media has now created this
illusion that if you have an opinion and
you put it online it's relevant and
people need to listen to it no you might
have a bad opinion or a poorly educated
opinion you know it's fine to have
opinions and we're all entitled to that
but sometimes your opinion is incorrect
and people need to know that people
think that like Stephen Fry does this
great stuff about being offended I'm
sure you've seen that where he'll
mention someone something and someone
will say I'm offended by that and he's
like okay yeah so what just because
you're offended it doesn't mean that I'm
wrong are you physically harmed that's
right yeah you know it's okay to be
offended yeah you know it doesn't made
my point not right it just means that
you don't agree with it somehow I feel
bad for I mean I don't think he cares
obviously but I feel bad sometimes
watching Bill Burr because he's such a
great comedian has such brilliant
material but very often throughout his
shows with people who have come
specifically to see Burr he has to get
he has to go and say okay I'm now going
to say something really upsetting right
right it's a joke right you've come to a
comedy show like just keep in mind
everything that I'm saying here is
trying to make you laugh and then he'll
say something and they'll just be like
oh and he's like yeah like yeah yeah a
lot of people think they especially in
the past couple years it feels like
people are using their opinions as a way
to elevate their status above other
people you know and you see it in
reactions online to things in the whole
like cancel culture movement which it
doesn't really seem like it's happening
anymore but it is that same energy of oh
I don't think that's right so let me put
you down so that I look like a better
person right right and and that happens
a lot in comedy too like the people that
hate Dave Chappelle right now you know
uh or like that woman who walked out of
my show she probably looked around the
whole room and thought all these people
are beneath me right I'm right here you
know what I mean so I'm gonna go home
and make some lavender tea and just
think about how good I am and maybe I'll
tweet about it and get three likes and
that'll be my day you know good times
it's wild
Billy and Dom eat the world well hey
William but should we eat the world oh
have you brought us anything have you
have you brought an idea you brought us
an idea haven't you Brent and then um
because we always like to eat something
and if we have a guest then we we
normally ask the guest to bring
something you know from their history or
from family or from the country they
grew up and just something sort of that
means something to them dude I should
have cooked it's okay because we have
one of the great cookies our producer
Johnny Cruz is one of the greatest Cooks
in all Christendom yeah incredible he's
cooked for us but like Billy said it's
fantastic that you brought something
that uh clearly means a lot to you can
you remember what you told me yeah dude
so um I've also been cooking for a
really long time like I said my family's
Italian so they kind of raised me in the
kitchen my mom taught me how to make
handmade pasta when I was a kid uh and a
lot of people during covid got into
bread yeah
a lot of bread making I got back into
pasta so I started making a lot of pasta
and then I made a I made like a separate
food page on Instagram to take pictures
of all my pasta dishes
yeah yeah and and now whenever I go out
to eat Italian like me and my girlfriend
are very picky now we're both like
restaurant food we were in a Boston a
couple of weeks ago there and I had one
of the best Italian meals yeah just
what'd you handle when it's legit and
and it was uh the the restaurant in
Boston was called limoncello and uh it
was just one of those great where the
the way it was like it was telling you
about where the dish came from you know
whose mother used to make it thank you
John and uh he's like hey the chef he'd
bring out a little you know half of this
yeah and say the chef wanted you to
taste this and it was like a lasagna or
something it was just amazing yeah yeah
and he's like hey you you need a glass
of wine yeah I've got the very and you
know you didn't really order just
they're just leaving the shop isn't that
awesome oh you don't have to do anything
it was just and it just tasted like it
was all made with love and the place was
great uh I loved it and then it's a good
Italian meal just can be beaten it's the
best it's fantastic it's the best right
yeah so so Brett during during covert
lockdown what were you what were your
standout pasta things so I was doing a
lot of
um homemade taglit Telly which is like
fettuccine and meat sauce a lot of meat
sauce a lot of steaks with vegetables or
a lot of like Bolognese or like a Ragu
or something like that and uh so I went
to it was my birthday celebrating my
birthday in 2021 me and my girlfriend
went to a restaurant in Santa Monica
based on a recommendation from a friend
and it ended up being awful we walked in
it was a great recommendation but we
walked in and like the the the plates
were like cold and the past the sauce
tasted like ketchup or like barbecue
sauce and ketchup mixed together the we
had caprese and the the tomatoes were
still kind of Frozen and the cheese
tasted like chalk it was so bad a lot of
mistakes there a lot of mistakes a lot
of issues what's wrong with these it's
nice we won't mention that restaurant we
won't mention it don't mention the name
DM me if you want to know yeah and and
so we left we left we said hey we don't
really want to pay for this it's awful
it's just not we're not having a good
time at all so we left and we went to a
different restaurant that we had been to
before and we walked over and this place
is called Via Veneto in Santa Monica and
I walked up to the guy and he said they
were kind of full uh and I begged him I
was like dude it's my birthday we went
to this other place they were really bad
and he was like oh what's the place
called and I told him the name and he's
super Italian and he go as soon as I
said the name he goes
we all know you cannot go they got no
Italians in the kitchen why are you
going to that plant place is trash you
can't go there what are you thinking and
he immediately sits us down and I pull
out my phone and I start showing him the
photos on my food page uh to show him
like whatever you make it just is like
you know to be friends and let him know
I'm here to eat and he calls over his
manager so look at the photos and they
start talking like super fast in Italian
like whispering to each other scrolling
through my Instagram page and then the
manager says he goes hey what so you
know I don't know what you do on the
side but if you're ever looking for a
job you could come cook with us maybe
you know you spend a week in the kitchen
we see how you do and I was like I don't
know if I could change careers but I I
really appreciate it so is that and
because you live in Santa Monica
Williams that ended up becoming your
favorite Italian in it again because I'm
gonna go yeah Via Veneto via
and what you've what you suggested today
is a classic
is from a region in Italy called
Bolognese is that where there's bologna
bologna Bologna Italy yeah I think it's
kind of central as my wife's go-to in an
Italian meal that's right yeah yeah me
too
tell me
um you said that you did a lot of sport
Growing Up watch sports
played basketball mostly that was my
main sport sizest
oh really the tallest guy wins
yeah you know generally you'll be quick
and sneaky yeah I said to Billy what
about that guy Boykins he was what was
he five foot five or something yeah Earl
Boykins Mugsy Bogues was five three they
should have a whole other leak drop a
drop at a foot no one's allowed in over
six foot yeah it's a faster League it's
a better game yeah we'll call it instead
of the NBA it's the SBA what's that for
Shire Basketball Association right I'm
loving it you know I love it so far
let's start it you you seem like a
Google you make Wayne you do food yeah
what's the name of your um Instagram
where we can look at your food oh the
food stuff is Brent's food
what a lovely uh imaginative name for it
yeah man um
I'm gonna read you a little blurb here
about Bolognese
and I'm just going to take a tiny bit
more weight would you mind just giving
me a snifter yeah
well listen wine and pasta is there
anything more
Vibe vibrous yeah William don't get me
drunk and make a passive no absolutely
never do that again
yeah just a sniff that nice lovely oh
yeah
a little kiss Thank you so how did um
before you read that please William
you're just on the sport how did um
um pastor at Italian and pasta every
night does that work with them you know
what's funny right when I was growing up
we never we were not as like health
conscious as we are today right you know
like we're talking about
Paul stamets and Zach Bush and holistic
Wellness which you know we love
obviously you love that because you're
wearing beaded bracelets like yes yes I
do and and uh
but when I was growing up we didn't know
any of that no we didn't know it at all
we had pasta uh dinner like team pasta
dinners the night before a game we would
all go to a kid's house order a mad
amount of spaghetti garlic bread
garlic knots pasta sauce is that like
nuts yeah like like a knot of dough
nuts
well and uh and we would eat like this
crazy amount of carbs and like processed
food the night before a high school
basketball game I can't imagine doing
that crazy you know there's professional
retired now but retired professional
football or soccer players who used to
talk about an hour and a half before the
game the team would ask them to sit down
and eat pasta and tuna or pasta and
chicken wow which obviously I understand
the protein element of it to a certain
degree but the pasta after half an hour
so you're gonna be oh you're gonna no
you're gonna crash yeah guys I'm gonna
read a little introductionary blurb to
The Bolognese sauce ladies and gentlemen
a blurb on The Bolognese sauce read by
my friend Mr Dominique Monahan thank you
William while the Quest for the most
traditional recipe to be leads to a much
heated debate in the motherland Italy it
is established that the history of the
bolognese sauce started in the 18th
century the first mention of the term
alabolanese appeared in Pellegrino
artusi's cookbook
perfect job thank you
science in the kitchen and the Art of
eating Well published in 1891. that is
impressive it is recognized as the most
famous Italian cookbook of modern times
and features nearly 800 uh recipes let
me tell you tonight after this I'm going
to go on Amazon and I'm going to see if
you can buy that book
I have never bought him a book yeah he
buys me a book sort of every week I saw
a book for him today and I was like I'm
not going to buy him seven books in a
row and have nothing to show for it well
really that would be a treat
how expensive is it inexpensive book do
you know that book I don't know that
book particularly but okay I love that
book how about notorious or famous
celebrity chefs is there anyone are you
finished with that is that was out there
no that was just the introduction that
was merely an order because I felt as if
I needed to know more
is there anyone on TV where you think
you know what actually that person is
pretty good and they know what they're
doing oh yeah uh Massimo botura oh right
you know who that is I don't actually
he's got uh restaurants in Italy is one
of the biggest chefs out there he's
these kooky wacky dude high energy
Italian guy
um another thing I did during 2020 was
watch a bunch of master class lessons
he's got a great Master Class lesson oh
great because
as well I learned ah what did I learn
isn't it funny you watch a whole lesson
yeah
like who else did you do you did him did
you do Gordon Ramsay
Gordon Ramsay do Gordon ramsays it's
incredible I did this other woman who's
like a home Chef so she does a lot of
like home like kind of almost easy
recipes I did um songwriting I did a I
did a Film Production one nice which was
good just to touch up a lot of school
sexy one yeah that's the one I did it
was great there's a great Dustin Hoffman
one about acting he's a bit wagonal
crazy oh and then I did the astronaut
not one dude to learn how to go to space
yeah
I want to do that that's my number one
if if they end up making the trip from
Earth to the Moon into a vacation like a
a possible vacation would you do that
absolutely
without hesitation yeah it looks great
yeah at this point in my life I'm
getting older sure if they said
we need something to go to Saturn but
it's a one-way trip
because normally they send dogs up and
they don't bring them back right no
that's very sad they might start doing
that with humans if they do I would like
that too there's also an Aaron Sorkin
masterclass and I think your favorite TV
show of all time is The West Wing right
now I would say he talks about
screenwriting very a very deep dive into
screenwriting sure but it's fantastic I
was going to ask you something then
oh gosh I can't remember it was
something about cooking oh I know well
I'm gonna go around the around the room
oh that's Brent right William over there
and myself
I'll begin just to give you guys a
little hint as to what I'm looking for
here you're number one top tip in
cooking
I'll give you mine right yeah this is
basically a phrase but it absolutely
works
if you boil a soup
you spoiler soup
nice never
boil a soup a simmer at best
I'm just gonna leave that with you great
finale yeah yeah phenomenal tip thank
you Brent
um
William
uh if uh if you don't wash your hands
you'll probably kill your grants
brilliant
that's a good one yeah renter yeah I'd
say
um
always taste it
never waste it was that I just thought
of that right now but that's great do
you mean like taste as you go taste as
you go always taste as you go and then I
really try not to waste food so like
even scraps I'll try to put into a bone
broth or something like that yeah I'm
going to put you guys in a nightmare
scenario
like 15 cats and there's another one
getting turned hotter and hotter now
okay just checking Guam
I'd already cracked the eggs yeah into
the bowl to make some scrambled eggs
this morning because I don't know if
I've told you I'm bulking up just now oh
yeah so I was gonna ask yeah I'm getting
you know sure so a lot of eggs
and uh a dumb I'm listening I put the
eggs in the bowl I've just about to make
them
no salt oh
I'll tell you what a dead have I had
cayenne pepper I had pepper I had garlic
salt oh yeah that might do it yeah it's
extreme it's strong flavor yeah and I
had some cream
go on some cream did you have any butter
probably didn't use it that's okay did
you have celery salt no I like it celery
sauce I only had garlic salt the garlic
salt is great can you use that yeah like
salt
I'm gonna say were you gonna say the
same thing a little less than normal
sparingly bills that's right don't make
a habit out of it but does it give the
you know that fact that salt has where
it brings out all the other flavors or
does the garlic garlic the garlic is
Like a Knife yeah the Garlic's over well
yeah but I would say but use a quarter
of what you would normally use for sauce
if in a bind I kind of what I did and I
didn't really taste the garlic too much
but I definitely missed the salt yeah
yeah I wouldn't do it too often no
William let me ask you a slightly
leading question here he made scrambled
eggs this morning you mentioned just
then that you put the scrambled eggs in
a bowl to mix it all together and then
put it in a pan
seems like you're absolutely forgetting
the the way you made that method that I
told you which William you said was the
greatest scrambled eggs you've ever had
in your life are you lying are you lying
to me if if you uh
ask me am I like I would have to say yes
it's not the greatest scrambled eggs
the actual Gordon method with the cold
butter yeah it is like Billy said it's
20 minutes or so but his thing is crack
your eggs directly into the pan and you
have it on a low heat as soon as it
starts to grab onto the bottom of the
pan take it off stir it cool it down yup
what he's wanting is heat cool heat cool
heat cool you do that like four or five
times add in butter and cream cheese or
creme fraiche or something it's
incredible but you've been lying to me
for months now no it was very good eggs
it was very good but it's not your
favorite no maybe I've been my favorite
but the pan was already on I was running
late as you know he's got excuses now
and there's no soul
but I mentioned that before
and I just I just made it very fast all
right hey can I make a recommendation
for you when you are now buying Seoul
possibly on the way home yeah will you
invest in a lovely box of molden salt
right and I normally do
m-a-l-d-o-n oh yeah as soon as you have
mold and salt it's hard to go about this
yeah would you like Himalayan salt I
love it I like sea salt I like sea salt
but I prefer anything volcanic Celtic
yeah yeah Celtic yeah
Celtic salt and so I remember it yeah
never get them confused never get Celtic
water and spring sauce or never no no no
you can't tell us something else about
Bolognese pasta I'll tell you something
now uh continuing on with delicious
willing uh continuing on from
um Mr what is his name it doesn't say
the first message
2z so in his book he says in his
Bolognese
he added veal and pancetta no mention of
beef as well as onion carrots celery
flour broth salt pepper
nutmegan no cheese small amount of cream
added at the end of the preparation is
optimal is sorry optional but
recommended dried mushrooms you love a
mushroom Billy
I'm just thinking they're optional and
optimal you get those confused you can
really change
a few slices if you're feeling decadent
of truffle mushrooms fantastic or
chicken leather it can also be included
for added flavor from this recipe The
Bolognese sauce evolved over the years
with every cook putting their own spin
on it but basically saying this staying
the same so much of that recipe
doesn't have much in common with the
original nowadays but there's a few
things that you kind of don't change
your whole onion carrot celery yeah salt
pepper not make it's a very
Moorish kind of comforting food
spaghetti bondage why your wife likes it
so much I don't know I think she just
like and and you know when you've had a
good one you're like oh I'd like that
again yeah could you grill it tonight
could you set it down yeah face to face
what do you like yeah talk is talk us
through yours Brent yeah yeah it's funny
you know in Italy uh everybody thinks
they have the best recipe and even on
one street two ends of the street can
make it completely different than each
other of course it's crazy
um so mine I actually use bison a lot
wow
maybe you could do this but and as
jewelry you know what I mean could you
could you tell us how you make yourself
yes man so usually I get out
I get out of a four-hour sauna
just after I've finished doing three
hours of Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
and I'll go home
and I'll start with a Sofrito which is
celery onion and carrots
now that's a little reduction in the pan
is that that's just the veg okay you
wanna you wanna cook down the veg get it
caramelized and evaporate the water
and then what I'll do is I'll add the
Bison the fresh ground bison to the Pan
Man
and will Brown the meat right and saw a
little bit of pepper a little bit of
garlic in there too man
and then what we'll do is We'll add
tomato paste highly concentrated Jamie
can you pull up that link to tomato
paste yeah there it is right there if
you guys ever seen a giraffe eat a
bucket of tomato paste well it's being
tackled by a wolf it's wild man hey so
I'll cook down the tomato paste in that
mixture then I'll add red wine about a
half a bottle big fan of red wine let
that cook down let the water evaporate
let the alcohol evaporate turns into a
syrup man and then we'll bring in the
beef stock bone broth we'll mix that all
together we'll add the fresh herbs
typically Sage thyme Rosemary some
combination of those and then what we'll
do is we'll cook that whole thing down
until it's reduced to the point where if
an alien Came From Outer Space they
would see it and be like Joe I want to
have sex with your sauce man
and then we reduce it all the way down
and just before we Bond it with the
pasta we add a touch of cream lovely
what pasta that sounds nice yeah
I love that make me hungry and it was
funny as well I liked it all right it
made me think about that now hi bills
from behind the TV it made me think
about that now iconic little scene in
the first Godfather film where the guy's
teaching Michael how to make it oh with
the razors no no that's good Fellas oh
that's good Fellas the memory Godfather
Michael comes in yeah and all the big
boys are talking hey Michael come over
here let me show you something you take
your sauces you're taking meatballs your
red wine and Sonny comes up he's like
hey leave him alone he's not a cook he's
one of us but it's brilliant because if
you follow that recipe you're gonna have
a good breakfast phenomenal yeah hey
should we give it some skills yeah we
always score it and uh I think John did
a really good job because it's not easy
we've completely finished our plates
making something ahead of time and it's
you know you want that fresh Don't You
Wanna oh yeah yeah this is great it's
fantastic they give you a little spoiler
that is made with uh Beyond me wow no
real me in there lovely very healthy was
it also made with love could you tell us
John was it made with Beyond love or
just life
um okay now are we are we scoring this
Bolognese or bolognese
engine I think it has to be this this
one don't you think okay okay sure taste
yeah we do we use three categories
okay first one this is uh ten Brent you
can use decimal points if you right I'll
show you how I would do it I'm gonna
give that John it was delicious guys
I like a bit more sauce
pasta was slightly too Al Dente for me
oh yeah quite uh
and it was a paper plate a paper plate
um that's a disgrace I mean you you left
the restaurant because the plate wasn't
warm enough and John decides the server
on you know
a dead tree uh Dom
oh you're not happy no I'm happy because
I liked it but
I'd like them fresh from his cooker
seven point
five
that's quite critical was it well you're
known as the charitable scorer out of
the two of us and that was quite
critical well pasta can be difficult I'm
gonna say given the limitations of what
John had to deal with today well I look
in and then bringing it in I didn't know
we were taking that into account I
always do carry on I'm gonna give I'm
gonna give it a solid eight well that's
quite good so that's good that's good
yeah I uh when I had my first bite I was
gonna ask if it was chicken it tastes
like beef but now he said it's beyond
that makes so much sense
um I yeah I typically would do kind of a
looser sauce so that it's
a little more liquidy but take notes
you're you're a podcast producer yeah
that was forced to make a dish of pasta
uh so I got to be a little critical but
also give you the benefit of the doubt
lovely and um I do like the noodles
actually I prefer mine Al Dente like
this oh there you go it's got a it's got
a nice bite to the noodles the
springiness I I like the the size of the
carrots sometimes carrots can be
overwhelming they can be yeah and then
your whole dish tastes like carrots yeah
um John I'm going to give you I'm going
to give this a 7.3 lovely well that's
something that's all right John I'm from
an Italian mother jet Italian yeah one
that doesn't take any [ __ ] yeah
I I always enjoy
a little bit of fresh grated cheese
which we didn't have today and that's
okay I can't believe you left that edge
but it's okay now the second category
William is um Aesthetics how does it
look or how did it looks like sure when
you looked at it did you say that is
pleasing to the eye uh did you just
ignore Dom give us a score well this is
where I'm going to slightly demote John
although I enjoy him as a human
I agree with you guys I'd like a little
bit more of a tomatoey sauce anything
almost as if it's drowning a little bit
a shallow drown shallow sauce so
I'll give him a six
for Aesthetics out now as I said um a
plastic I mean paper plate straight away
no because you're quite high for Luton I
mean we're not in a picnic calorie
we're not Philistines and then the the
amount of pasta got was good but I'd
like it to be
exactly in the center of the plate oh
God John are you taking notes and pailed
up slightly like a like a shallow
volcano right and the lava coming out
the top is maybe the cheese no like the
sauce
and then I just um I mean you're
sprinkling almost like after a volcano
has went off the the dust that's
available
what a fresh sprig of Basil or as you
might say basil basil Nutella but it
felt as if John had no it aesthetically
didn't care what it looked like you're
angry with John today is there something
else going on have you guys had fun
like it was a dirty protest oh skill
score it then give him a critique
oh
I really can only give it a 6.2 oh it's
damning what did you what did you say
I'm pretty I'm picky when it comes to
presentation Johnson
when I was handed this plate of pasta I
felt like I was I was being handed a
plate of pasta at a family reunion by an
aunt who never really liked me yeah you
know it was slightly angry yeah I was
like oh I got caught sneaking out to let
out fireworks with my friend last night
and my mom told my aunt and my aunt
doesn't like me for it because I'm
getting my cousin involved in my
Shenanigans but she still has but she
has to feed me at the Family Reunion
yeah so as she feeds me she hands me the
plate and when she takes away her hand
she forms a middle finger yeah it's very
subtle so that she can kind of play it
off as if she didn't do that that's what
this plate of food felt like I can
understand
I gotta be honest
I was going to but then I thought you
know maybe we can make up for it at some
point he was a boat
um I'd say presentation wise I'd I'd uh
it was on the plate I'll give you that
it will go it was on the plate although
it was a paper plate as I have a man she
did mentioned that yeah it's become a
bit of an owl but trust that
I'd I'd give it you know
of 4.5 oh gosh
five John you went sub five
I had to uh worry about presentations
of the Friendship onion that's over a
year I would think isn't it at least and
you you didn't think presentation was uh
you had to worry about it whereas it's
always scored every week we score a
presentation John I didn't think the
plate was uh part of that that was just
the pasta just one single noodle you
would hold up and say yeah yeah I
thought your choice of noodle was good
though is that like a thick penne of
something
yeah so yeah I don't know if you guys
saw but when Brent gave that score I was
looking directly into John's eyes and he
smarted
I love you bud yeah I tell you what
though John made a hot sauce ones oh
yeah like from scratch from Chili's and
I tell you Brian yeah it would change
your life it was wonderful and a couple
of weeks ago there we had the hottest
paper in the world we had that on yeah
and you ate it yeah did you eat it raw
yeah yeah oh my God it was painful and I
got stomach cramped I thought I was I
thought I was going to shut myself off a
minor Sprint I didn't but
uh John now has those and he's going to
make a source from it I mean a a hot
sauce a hot sauce so you will let you
try that because he's amazing you're
amazing at doing that John yeah did you
follow that up with milk no we didn't
follow up with anything did we we just
raw dogged it yeah did you have milk I
had milk yeah it leaves a little bit
more yeah so yeah
so here's here's the last thing that we
score which is Billy's category that he
made up himself it's usefulness
how useful is this food I know Brent
you're thinking the same thing as most
guests which is what the [ __ ] yeah that
was the expression well see for instance
we take John's hot sauce yeah that is
useful oh yeah you've got that in the
cupboard doesn't matter like this
morning when I had eggs with no salt
yeah it wouldn't matter because I put
some of that hot sauce on it'd be some
of the best eggs you've ever tasted but
you didn't follow the Gordon Ramsay
method did you no I didn't know it's too
slow yeah it's good it's not really
worth it it's definitely worth it
but you know or say for instance we had
have you ever heard the jardinera no oh
what does it say a Chicago condiment
John would that be correct is it like
Italian families it is it's like a
relish and it's relationship it's not a
relation anyway it's a selection of uh
chopped up vegetables made into a relish
not a relish not a race in uh oil and
hot chili so everything becomes hot oh
my God see if you put that on a pizza oh
that sounds important you put it with
eggs yeah yeah yeah scrambled eggs
yeah
the New Zealand uh mama is like horses
piss but that's fine
how useful is it
see I think a Bolognese is incredibly
useful
um
in some instances but it's not very
productive to start incorporating into
your daily life
yeah yeah because it you need a minimum
of two hours if you really want to make
it right because you got to let it sit
you got to let it reduce nice glass of
wine
absolute go-to if you're gonna have a
party oh yeah
well you're well you're making it
absolutely you kill a bottle of vibe you
think about all the things in your life
that are going well you're having a
great time but once it's made and it's
there it's in the fridge right you've
eat it
yeah yeah I see yeah is it used well can
I can I throw something out there as a
kid can I put an egg on it right can I
I'm gonna throw something out there as a
kid a different way of enjoying
Bolognese which when I was younger was
incredible where do you hear this
Bolognese Pizza what do you think of
that so you use the bolognese sauce as
the tomato sauce base the cheese on top
incredible and then the cheese on the
sauce it's really fantastic pizza and
could you buy that from stores in
Manchester no no I lived in Germany as a
kid and uh they had it quite often in uh
German Italian restaurants that's just
good this is good fun decision
um yeah so how you it's not the most
it's not the most versatile I eat it
just straight up even without pasta
sometimes it's so good I'll just eat it
like chili I'll heat it up in a pan the
day after and I'll eat it like chili
well there you go I think we have to
give it some points for like you said a
house party house party
event Gala 10 out of ten if you're
having people over 10 out of ten people
are normally going to like it right yeah
daily usefulness
yes six
years like a a top boy it's incredible
yeah mine is pretty good yeah yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna but I do the same I
think yeah I'm getting it six as far as
versatility goes because there's really
only a couple places you could use it
but in those places it's a tent yeah for
sure and you can't put it in your pocket
you could depends on what you're wearing
where you're going where you're with I
like to think about you know can you can
you tour it around and take it half time
at a football game and hand it out to
the team and I don't think Bolognese is
great no like you don't want to bring it
to a party in a little baggy instead of
drugs it's just for somebody a little
piece
that's what it is right yeah right for
me it's a 5.2 yeah is it a six feet yeah
yeah that's about six well that was
Bolognese guys I think I think we've
done it Brent it's been fantastic having
you on how do people um appreciate you
guys see it what you guys uh what you
are up to online how do people yeah man
it's uh Brent's Pella p-e-l-l-a you
could type that into YouTube Instagram
Facebook find all the videos watch all
the things
very funny stuff it's been lovely having
you all thanks for the following me
suggestion absolutely thanks for
enjoying the vibe dude I appreciate it
as well it's really good it's really
good I'm glad man thank you so much I
look forward to you sending me a very
steamy photo letting on if you're in the
bath having finished off that glass of
uh when you chill it right down when I
go home while I draw a bathroom yeah I
love that you draw a bus
stop yeah
lovely love it thank you very much
thanks for coming on oh yeah guys we'll
see you next week on the Friendship
onion don't forget to send emails uh
speakpike.com forward slash the
Friendship onion yeah and anything else
that you need to know you can find out
in the show notes uh below and we'll see
you next week see you next week
harmonize with me
[Music]